في عالم اللغات فعلى الرغم من صعوباتها
تمكنت اللغه الصينيه من احتلال المرتبه
الثانيه بعد الانجليزيه كاكثر لغه انتشارا
في العالم طبعا بحسب موقع
تجمع الصينيه ما بين العدد الهائل من
الناطقين بها ومن يستخدمونها ايضا كلغه
ثانيه هذا بالفعل جهود السلطات الصينيه
التي بسطتها بهدف القضاء على الاميه لاحقا
ومع توسع التجاره مع العملاق الصينيه
ارتفع الطلب على خدمات الترجمه الصينيه
والبحث عن مترجمين فوريين
ويعتبر معظم المترجمين اللغه الصينيه اصعب
لغه بل
انها الناطقين بها وتتطلب ايضا خبره واسعه
لكن المزيد حول اللغه الصينيه ومعلومات قد
تدهشك رح يكون مع على سرحان وطبعا في لغات
صحيه كثيره ابرزها واشهرها الماندرين يعني
علاء بيتكلم صيني
ولا لا يعني يلا يلا نتكلم عربي اذا اللغه
الصينيه يعود تاريخها لاكثر من 3000 سنه
وتكتب من اليسار الى اليمين او من اعلى
الى اسفل هناك واحد من كل سته اشخاص
يتحدثوا اللغه الصينيه واكثر من مليار شخص
يتحدثون بها كلغتهم الام ما يفوق عدد
المتحدثين باللغه الفرنسيه والالمانيه
والاسبانيه والانجليزيه مجتمعين لغه لا
تعتمد على الابجديه هذا ما يجعل نظام
الكتابه فيها صعب جدا بالاضافه لاحتوائها
على الاف الحروف المستقله كما ان اللغه
الصينيه تحتفظ بنفس شكل الاسماء ايا كانت
هي مفرد او جمع ايضا لا تحتوي على ازمنه
للافعال الخاصه بها فبدلا من استخدام لعب
ويلعب يتم استخدام قبل وبعد للتعبير عن
الزمن كما ان نغمه الصوت في اللغه الصينيه
تغير المعنى تماما لذا هذا ما يفسر نطق
الصينيين لبعض الكلمات بصوت اعلى وتعد
اللغه الصينيه لغه رسميه من اللغات الست
في الامم المتحده
[موسيقى]
طيب نروح الى بس هذه مو فرقه كعب ولا
خطوتها
ولا شينان الصينيه طبعا الطالب المبتعد
حامد الهنائي موجود هناك خلينا نعرف شو
اسم المنطقه اول شيء صبحك الله بالخير
صباح الخير
صبحكم الله بالنور لا حنا بعدكم نحنا
باربع ساعات باربع ساعات
طيب اسم المدينه شي ان شي ان
هذه انا قبل كم سنه رحت 2018 رحت بكين ما
عرفت اتعامل لانه اللغه صعبه وحتى نطقها
ودامينز عادل يعني اذا كان هذا اسمي ما
ادري انا قاعد اقولها صح ولا غلط
قريب قريب شفت شلون تعلمتها سهله
بدايه تعلمتها
بدايتي وانا في المدرسه سوي نظام دوله
الامارات بدو مشروع اللغه الصينيه من كان
عمري يمكن ثلاث سنوات سبع سنوات لين يومك
هذا
فاليوم الامارات او دول عربيه او الدول
الخليجيه قاعد تستثمر في الطلاب عشان يكون
عندهم خبره زين كافيه عشان يتعاملون
الاشخاص الصينيين طب يا حامد انت بتقول من
من وهو عمرك سبع سنين بلش تتعلم اللغه
الصينيه بنحكي عن مضبوط الماندرين تحديدا
معنى ذلك بانه هلا انت صرت بلبل زي ما
بيقولوا
نوعا ما ولكن في مستويات في اللغه
امتحانات جدا ولكن ما اشوف في مع تدريب
واحد يتعلم بشكل فعال يستخدم مثلا مصادر
ثانيه سواء انا مثلا كنت
ادرس في الامارات
صار موضوع كورونا وصار هذا تاجلت امور اني
انتقل للجامعه بشكل اسرع لكن الواحد لازم
غير انه يدرس مثلا الجامعه لازم هو
يستخدم مصادر نفس الكتب يشوف افلام
يشوف اصدقاء سنين يتعرف عليهم اليوم بشكل
اسهل واحد يتعرف على ناس هل نعم
حامد هل من السهوله ان انت تتعامل مع
الصينيين بلغتهم انه يعني قد تخطئي
يعلمونك
النطق الصحيح للكلمه هناك ايضا يعني
الجامعات الصينيه في عندها اقسام للغه
العربيه ولكن حتى من يتحدث اللغه العربيه
اجت صعوبه في التعامل معاه
بالنسبه للصين صحيح انا انا بالنسبه لي
اول شيء نبدا في اللغه الصينيه هي من
اللغات الصعبه والمعقده بشكل عام ليش
هي تتميز بنظام
مختلفه عن جميع اللغات الاخرى سواء سواء
كانت مثلا كوريا ولا هذا الدول المقربه
لها هي نظامها مختلف تماما بالكتابه نتحدث
لانها رموز كليات نعم نعم وايضا في الصوت
مختلف تماما يعني يستخدم الواحد يوم يقول
كلمه يستخدم اصوات للتعبير عن المعاني
يعني بشكل مختلفه بعطيكم مثال يوم واحد
اذا يقول كلمه
هذه كلمه بما معناها رقم اربعه اوكي لكن
اذا قالها بشكل
هذي كلمه بعيد الشر والله يطول في عمركم
معناها الموت
فمرات اذا الواحد يقولها بشكل سريع مثلا
ما يلقطها
خاصه اذا انا مثلا اكلم واحد صيني وما
يلقطها بشكل صحيح يفهم المعنى بشكل ثاني
مختلف
ممارسه بشكل كبير اكيد صعب جدا لانه يعني
مش بس حتى لو تعلمت الاحرف وهي مش احرف هي
رموز هل الكتابه ايضا صعبه مش بس النطق
يعني انت تتحدث عن اصوات مختلفه لنفس
الكلمه تعطي معنى مختلف بالنسبه
للكتابه هذه رموز كلها يعني مختلفه عن اي
لغه ثانيه احنا متعودين عليها
ايوه هذا الرموز اصلا قبل تعود تعود قبل
هذه الرسوم كان في ثلاث مراحل كانت مرحله
كانت رسم قبل تطورت كانت رسم الى كتابه
الحين صارت الى كتابه لكن اليوم اذا نشوف
كلمات مثلا
كثيره موجوده في الصيني واحد يعرف معانيها
يشوف المعنى موجود في الكلمه
اشياء تعبر عن شيء مثلا كلمه الماي او
كلمه النار فيها شيء يعني يعني فيها حاطين
نفس جناحة وهذا فتبين انها مثلا نار اذا
الواحد يعود الى معناها قبل او كيف كانت
تتم كتابتها تكون رسمه تمام طيب حامد كيف
تقول صباح الخير صباح العربيه ولا حتى
صباح الخير بالصيني
ايوه صحصح الحين صحي هي ولا صح انا
منو صح
لازم اراضيكم لكن صحي صحي حمد
العلمي راويه العالمي طيب شكرا جزيلا الله
يعينك يا حامد على على يعني وعلى تعلم
اللغه الصينيه وان شاء الله ترجع وتكون
دائما من المبدعين ونستفيد دائما من خبرات
ان شاء الله شكرا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات